[Captions by Y Translator]
Today's video is sponsored
by PUBG Mobile.
In the game PUBG, the supply crates
are full of all sorts of goodies,
ammo, Med kits,
and other accessories.
Well today, we're going to try
building a miniature supply crate,
stuffing it full of loot,
and then dropping it
from a couple hundred feet out of a drone.
[Music]
The crate we're building,
I'm going to shoot
for approximately one foot cubed.
In fact, it'll end up being
a little bit bigger than that
because the main box will be one foot,
and then we'll have little bits
of extra trim on the outside.
Just trying to make it look more
like the one in the game.
But to start out, we've got these boards
about a quarter of an inch thick,
and we need to cut out
some one foot squares.
[Music]
I've got a bunch of squares cut,
and I also have this one by two
board that I ripped down the middle.
We're going to cut four one
foot lengths off of this,
and we're going to use that
as sort of the corner supports
to hold our cube together.
[Music]
We're using wood glue,
and some finishing nails
just hold this all together,
and these nails are not long enough
to go through the wood into the table.
I promise.
[Music]
We got five sides of our box.
It is feeling pretty sturdy.
Now, we need to add a lid.
However, I want to be able to remove
this lid without destroying the box.
This isn't the crate that
you actually are going
to need a pry bar to take apart.
And so, the mechanism
that's going to hold this on
will be a little bit different.
We're just going to have
four little pieces of wood
on the sides that will just fit
really snug down into there.
So the lid will hold itself on,
but if you try and lift it off,
it could come off fairly easily.
Lid holds itself on,
but not so tightly
that you can't just lift it off.
Now, the supply crates in PUBG
are not smooth walled,
and I think they're actually made of metal.
And while ours is made of wood,
we are going to try
and match the look a little bit.
They have sort of a bumpy
pattern along each side,
and so what  we're going to do
is take five strips
of are thinner wood
that all fit along the side,
and we're going to taper them
so that they give this sort
of in and out look
that we have in the game.
[Music]
These aren't currently attached yet
because we want to wait
for the spacing until we have
the side pieces on this well,
but here's what those
are going to look like,
giving us that corrugated effect.
Now, we need the sides,
and those are going to be
a little bit thicker.
We're going to do those two layers thick
because they stick out farther
than these corrugations.
So we're going to cut off
some more thin strips.
We're going to glue two strips
together to get that thickness,
and then we're going to bevel
one sides we can get two
of them to match up at the corners nicely.
We want to attach those
to all four corners of our crate.
[Music]
With our corner pieces
attached, we can now go
about spacing out the side bars.
[Music]
Our crate is really
starting to take on
the look that I was hoping for.
We've got the high edges.
We've got the corrugation
in the middle.
We've got top and
bottom rims on everything.
I'm liking it.
One more addition we do need to make is
that there are these little corner pieces
that go over every one of these angles.
So I've made 16 of those,
just out of some scrap pieces,
and we're just going to glue
and nail those in place.
[Music]
That is looking like a crate.
Now, we need to do some painting
to get it to match.
In the game, these are
sort of a faded red color.
So we've got faded red paint.
Although first, we're going
to use a little bit of wood putty
and then some primer.
[Music]
The supply crates are
not just a wooden box.
They also have what appears
to be a blue tarp over them,
as well as some black straps
wrapping around the whole thing.
So this board here is
about the size of our lid,
and we just need to leave
enough extra space on the sides
that we can get the hanging
over folded look that we're going for.
That shouldn't actually
take too much.
However, every picture I've seen
of the crate does make it look
like there's no finished edge on the tarp,
or at least not much.
There's no grommets
or anything like that.
So we are just going to go for bare tarp,
something where there's no finishing,
or seams, or grommets on it.
[Music]
It is time to turn this supply crate
into a crate full of supplies.
So what we've gone and done is
we have a bunch of PUBG t-shirts,
and these are going to go
in the supply crate.
And then assuming that everything works,
assuming this thing survives being dropped
as we hope it will,
we're going to send the crate
and the shirts to one lucky fan.
Before I throw t-shirts in,
one more thing I'm going to do,
I am going to sign this bad boy.
Put some time
and effort into it.
[Music]
With our crate all
loaded up with goodies,
we can now put our tarp over it,
and wrap some straps around it.
We've got ourselves some webbing here,
and we need two bands going
each direction, so four bands total.
[Music]
Our PUBG supply crate,
our airdrop is built.
And that thing is looking great.
That looks just like the one
in the game in my opinion.
Although, of course,
much smaller.
It can't fit--
We're doing mini version,
and that,
that looks like a mini version
of the crate.
Now, it needs a parachute,
and we're going to use the same design
and materials that Grant showed you how
to use in a previous video
of how to make the parachute
for the sky balls.
So we're going to be using
the same materials that
dollar store tablecloth plastic.
Although, it's gonna be quite a bit bigger
because this thing weighs about 7.5 pounds.
3.38 kilos.
So we are going to need a bit
more strength on our parachute.
Here is my thought.
I'm pretty sure that even this piece,
if I were cut,
if I were to cut a square this wide,
I'm pretty sure that would still be
too small of a parachute.
I want bigger than that.
In fact, I want four
times bigger than that.
So I'm going to take two
of these pieces,
tape them together lengthwise,
and then make a square out of that.
So it's going to be
a big old parachute.
This table's not big enough.
[Music]
Random fact: By the fifth day after D-Day,
104,428 tons of supplies had been
dropped on the beaches of Normandy.
[Music]
Let's do a quick test,
which will involve
me holding these strings and running.
See if this parachute inflates.
[Music]
Well, I'd say it's
parachuting pretty good.
We'll just have to see how well it works
when we're actually hanging a box from it,
and dropping it off a drone.
There's a slight chance of the box
is just going to hit the ground,
and the parachute won't open.
That'd be exciting too.
The four chords attaching
to our parachute will be connected
to this swivel hook,
and now, we need to attach
the swivel hook onto the box.
And then to do that
using some elastic,
and hopefully, that will
give a little bit of give
if the parachute catches really suddenly.
Now, we're going to have
an additional strand
of paracord attached to this hook,
and then extend sort of up in
between these chords all the way
through our parachute,
and then out the top,
we'll have a very tiny hole.
And we're just going
to fit our paracord
with a loop through that,
and that's what we're going
to use to attach it to our drone.
Hopefully, by doing that,
we'll keep the parachute away from any
of the dangerous parts of the drone.
It won't get in the blades
or anything like that.
It just seems like that
might be a good way to do it.
Have the crate hanging
below the parachute,
lift it up, drop it.
Obviously, a real supply drop parachute
is going to have its own bag,
and it's going to pop open and...
But we are not making
that official of a replica here.
[Music]
PUBG mobile,
if you're not familiar with it,
tt's a battle royale game,
which means it's you
versus everyone else out there.
You can play with teammates,
but it's a small little squad
of up to four people.
So you just go around,
you grab weapons,
vehicles, armors, supplies, and you just
try and beat everyone else out there.
It's last man or last
squad standing.
So you've played PUBG
for a while, right?
>> Yeah.
One of my--
It's my favorite game actually.
>> Have you played it
on any other platform?
Yeah.
I've actually played it on Xbox.
I prefer the mobile version
a little bit better.
I'm much better at the controls
on mobile than I am on Xbox.
>> I'm playing as a very
very new player right now,
but I mean, controls
seem pretty simple to get used to.
>> Yeah. I think it's really intuitive.
It's...
You can pick it up really fast.
Like, I've played this
with people who have
never played this style of game before,
and they picked it up really quick.
>> You can customize
the controls quite a bit too.
>> Yeah, you can.
You can move around all the sites,
and your shoot button,
or pick up button,
or just kind of jump button.
Where exactly.
>> Wherever you want your thumbs to be.
Yeah.
>> That's good.
So, this game's got some pretty realistic
high-end top-of-the-line graphics
with Unreal Engine controlling everything.
>> Yeah. It definitely
makes a difference.
You can totally tell
that there's a lot
of detail in the graphics,
and the rendering that's going on.
>> You suggested when I started playing
that I use some nice headphones,
because it's got
like good audio built into them,
and stuff like that too, right?
>> Yeah, so it's actually a way better
experience having headphones
while playing this game,
cause you can hear where
people are around you.
>> The sound is brought to you
with Truth 3D audio 7.1 channels,
so you hear stuff just all around you.
We're playing on one map now.
How many maps are there?
>> There's three maps,
and they're really big,
and they have a lot of detail.
>> The game has a variety
of different modes available,
including some faster paced arcade modes,
and those include War mode,
mini zone, sniper training,
and quick matches.
Guys, join over 100 million players
currently playing PUBG Mobile.
The game is completely
free to play.
The download link is
in the description below.
>> And we died.
>> Oh.
That's pretty cool. We did good.
>> We've got our crate.
We've got our giant drone,
and now we're going to see what happens
if we pick this thing up,
and drop it.
Hopefully, the parachute will open,
and it will glide gently to the ground.
If that parachute doesn't work,
then we are going to have
a red crate shaped missile
headed toward the ground,
and I just hope it looks
cool when it explodes.
[Music]
We're away.
Alright, hitting the switch.
Three, two, one.
[Music]
It opened.
It's still coming in pretty quick,
but it opened.
I'm going for it.
[Music]
Whoo!
Hoo!
Supply crate, found.
Intact and everything.
GoPro attached.
Parachute, not 100% destroyed.
Whoo!
Success.
[Music]
Well, I think it's even
windier than last time.
[Music]
Ooh.
Parachute struggling
a little bit.
Well, it's coming down hard.
It stayed intact.
Well, that had some force coming down,
but I think it--
I think the box is okay.
The parachute is not so okay.
Our parachute has suffered.
I'm going to call
that critical failure.
This string is not really
attached too much anymore.
I'm not sure if that happened before
or after we dropped it.
But the box, I think
the box survived alright.
I'm gonna say it means
I built it well.
Very cool.
So one very successful drop,
and one semi-successful drop.
That did not completely destroy it,
so I'm calling that a win.
And we are now
doing a giveaway.
We have filled this thing with some loot,
and we're going to be sending it
to one lucky winner.
Check the link
in the description for details.
Guys, thanks for watching.
But that's not all,
we've got more for you to see.
That box up of the top
will transport you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you aren't a subscriber,
just hit this bomb to get in the club.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.